hi I'm Florence rose I'm a model and a
makeup artist if you want to find out
how to create this fresh dewy makeup
look then keep watching so first of all
I like to prime my face and I'm using
sceeto's jewelry spritz I'm just taking
this and doing a light spritz all over
my face and fanning it to make sure that
it's dry then moving on to base I'm
using makeup Forever's Ultra HD
Perfector this is great for my skin tone
as it matches perfectly and it's really
good to create a dewy natural look I'm
dotting this all over my face to map out
the areas I want to cover and then using
a brush I'm blending this out initially
then taking slightly more putting under
my eye and blending us out with a small
Beauty Blender just to cover those dark
circles
next moving on to blush I like to use a
cream blusher and this is the CYO
cosmetics in shade storyteller I like to
use a cream blush because it's creamier
and a more natural look I'm applying
this along my cheekbones and on the
apples of my cheeks slightly and across
the top of my nose to create a more
natural sunkissed lush so to get more
warmth on the face I'm using the laura
mercier bronzer i'm just taking an
angled brush and applying this along my
cheekbones along with bringing it up
towards my forehead and slightly around
my jaw as this is the areas that the Sun
will hit making it look like a natural
town now for highlight I'm using makeup
Forever's liquid highlighter I really
love this highlighter as it's very
Pelisson very natural-looking and goes
nicely with the blush and my pink hair
I'm taking this and putting on the back
of my hand then using my finger to apply
to my cheekbone along my brow bone the
tip of my nose the arch of my nose and
also along the Cupid's bow as I like to
wear a lot of highlight
and then to add a little sparkle and
make it quite festival wearable and
taking lime crime diamond to using the
brush that comes with applying this to
my lid and blending out of my finger I
love this product as it's very easy but
gives you a glam and ready to go look
the lips I'm using Nyx's dura chromatic
shimmer lip gloss in shades to bring it
on this is a great product it's a lovely
color and it catches highlights and
gives a gold shimmer to your lip so
lastly I'm adding some fake freckles
using two products one the Kiko Milano
eyebrow marker in shade three which is
slightly darker also the Laura Mercier
bronzer in shade two with more of a warm
tone I like to add freckles as it gives
more of a natural sunkissed look almost
like you're wearing no makeup
for more videos like this subscribe to
glamour UK's YouTube channel
[Music]